hey everybody as requested this is my
spider-man Easter egg video just careful
for spoilers if you haven't seen it yet
let's keep doing the ticket giveaway at
least through the end of this week and
then we'll change it to something else
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
let's see if I can do this in under 10
minutes but the first big Easter Egg is
they obviously use the 1960s TV theme
and weave it into the beginning of the
movie they introduced damage control to
the Marvel Cinematic Universe that's
just a cleanup crew it was a comic book
created by Dwayne McDuffie may he rest
in peace he was also the creator of the
static character so a lot of you might
remember him more for that stuff but in
the comics damage control was a joint
venture from people like the kingpin and
Tony Stark to clean up New York City it
was mostly localized to New York just
because so many of the classic
adventures took place around that area
but then there's the big Howard Stark
cameo and Peter's school the symbol of
the atom is the same symbol that you see
in Iron Man 2 when Tony is looking at
all this stark Expo stuff so I wouldn't
be surprised if Howard Stark or the
stark foundation or his family were big
benefactors for a lot of the schools in
town you even see them drive by Flushing
Meadows Park which is where the stark
Expo took place way back during the
original Captain America movie and then
in present day during Iron Man 2 they've
since confirmed that the little kid with
the Iron Man mask is now Peter Parker so
that might have something to do with the
eight years later so it would make sense
that he was 7 years old and this there's
so many people wondering about that
eight years I just did a video about it
so I'll link that at the end of this but
beyond the Civil War footage there is a
brief Bruce Banner cameo he's up in
Peter's classroom here so there's just a
lot of famous scientists that people
Revere that they celebrate in this
school because it's a science and tech
school there's even Abraham Erskine in
there too he was the doctor that created
the Super Soldier Serum Peters locker
combination 1184 November 1984 was the
release of the comic where Peter Parker
takes his symbiote costume ever he's
come back to earth to the Baxter
building and mr. fantastic reveals that
it's not just a costume is actually a
symbiote I think that was issue number
258 so big venom issue I know
everybody's wondering about what they're
going to do with the Venom symbiote when
Venna movie comes out next year we'll
hear more about that at Comic Con
probably there were a bunch of comic
book characters that didn't seem like
comic book characters in the movie
Cindy moon who is the silk character was
a big person
Ned Leeds who became Hobgoblin Flash
Thompson was kind of controversial
because he doesn't look like the flash
Thompson of the comics pretty sure he's
never going to become venom space knight
but the actor who plays them is totally
down for it so because these kids are so
young it just seems like if they're
actually going to do some of the
spider-verse characters that'll be
something that Sony does in ten years
down the road with different actors
they've won at the end of the movie
though was the Michelle MJ character so
obviously you probably heard now I've
talked about it in a couple other videos
she's an original character that they're
calling MJ because her full name is
Michelle Jones so the way Kevin Feige is
explaining it is that she's just a twist
on a classic comic book dynamic with
Peter Parker
Mary Jane very big love interest but
they wanted to do something different
with that dynamic they didn't want to
recycle the character again so it
implies a lot about where they're going
to take that character in the future but
obviously she's nothing like comic book
mary jane so there really bothers you
just think of hers Michelle don't worry
about it the book that she's reading
here in this scene Human Bondage isn't
about bondage at all the Easter egg is
more of a metaphor for Peter Parker's
story it's about an orphan boy that goes
to live with his aunt and uncle it has
these grand aspirations but finds
himself drawn to more mundane things
like getting married having children so
that's just like Peter Parker he wants
to be spider-man he goes to live with
his aunt and uncle but then he needs
people like Mary Jane he wants to get
married have children with them so it's
this push-pull between being spider-man
and being Peter Parker you probably
recognize Martin Starr all of his scenes
got a bunch of laughs in my theater but
he also starred in the Incredible Hulk
working with Bruce Banner just like
Jennifer Connelly the voice of Peters
suit AI the suit lady Karen who was
Betty Ross and a leaves Hulk so you have
a lot of Hulk crossover with the movie
in a really meta way the wife of Jarvis
in real life is the voice of
spider-man's AI so it sounds like she'll
actually come back for that
film - so way more hole crossover than
you ever thought baby will get actual
Hulk in the next film the Stan Lee cameo
was great he wasn't talking about any
comic book stuff Margery how's your
mother doing just a random guy in Queens
yelling at people to be quiet the bank
holdup though where they're all wearing
the Avengers mask is right out of the
comics it was an ultimate spider-man
number 42
that's another Bendis comic Bendis
actually got a special shout out during
the movie because there's so much
ultimate spider-man in this - just like
nedley's is basically the ganky
character you have Miles Morales which
was another huge easter egg you have his
uncle the Prowler which was basically
the backdoor to Miles Morales I have a
nephew in this neighborhood when he's
trying to get information out of him
about the weapons ferry you notice his
the license plate says uscm oh one
that's ultimate spider-man one the first
issue that referenced Miles Morales the
other license plate on the ferry in the
background here SM 205 63 was the first
appearance of the vulture where he and
spider-man fought there right on the
cover here so a lot of license plate
Easter eggs there's all those badass
Avengers weapons that Tony's working on
at the end of the movie they're loading
onto the plane
Thor's magic belt which i think is
pronounced Megan you're I'm probably
doing it wrong but it basically makes
him twice as strong as he normally is so
Thor's already super strong even without
the hammer he puts the belt on he gets
crazy Opie so because we're heading into
infinity war you hear he's making a
prototype for Cap's new shield
it's basically them teasing bit Tony
Stark is beefing up the Avengers in
anticipation of fan o's coming so the
prototype for caps new shield could just
be a regular new vibranium shield or it
could be more modular on agents of
shield Clark Gregg has been using caps
energy shield which is right out of the
comics but there's all kinds of villains
that pop up you have the Mac Gargan
scorpions it shows up he even has a
scorpion tattoo on his neck you have two
versions of the shocker
the first version isn't from the comics
but the Boheme would by inversion where
the voter says year the shocker now in
throws in the gauntlet he's Herman
Schultz he's the original shocker in the
gauntlet that they use is actually
Reaper
from crossbones gauntlet back during
civil war that he lays cap out with so
there's a bunch of Easter eggs and all
the stuff that they steal and repurpose
into new weapons the sub Voltron arm
when Peters on the back of that truck
there's even a tentacle that looks like
it belonged to Doctor Octopus back from
the tobey maguire era and then when he's
pulling stuff out of the bag he pulls an
Ultron head out with red eyes implying
that it's still alive so just a funny
way to invoke big things from previous
Marvel movies but there's a howling
commando
that's principal of Peters school so a
lot of you probably noticed that this
character was the same person that
showed up during the original Captain
America movie but it's just the same
actor he's not playing the same
character there was that huge dig at the
original spider-man kiss kiss or Peter
now's your moment before they pull it
right out from under him lots of jokes
about the previous spider-man films
including the amazing spider-man where
flash is driving up with his date saying
that branzino wasn't fresh that's a
reference to the fish dinner did
spider-man was eating at Gwen Stacy's
house during amazing spider-man a lot of
you said that you loved that spider-man
moment where he lifts the debris off his
head that's right at a Jack Kirby
amazing spider-man number 33 it's
literally a reference to that there were
a whole bunch of funny t-shirts that
Peter wore during the film Ironman even
wore a cat on his t-shirt but at the end
of the movie where he goes to the
Avengers building and sees the new
Spider suit he's wearing the same
t-shirt that Pepper Potts was wearing
during Iron Man 3 when she was in bed
with Tony which of course we know after
that moment she pops out and says
where's the kids the people are ready we
need to think of something the ring that
Happy's had in his pocket since 2008 is
just a reference to the og Marvel
Cinematic Universe team basically the
three people that set it off so this was
the beginning of the Marvel Universe
they're mostly making a joke about their
original work on that first Iron Man
film which is really touching you hear
them talk about how special that was and
how big a risk it was for Marvel and how
big everything's got since then how far
they've come it's amazing
the post-credits scenes the iron spider
suit all that stuff I've done videos
about so I'll link that at the end of
this but those were most of the big
comic book Easter eggs in the film there
were a lot of other references that I've
talked about in other videos that I
don't quite consider Easter eggs but if
you spotted a need that I didn't mention
in the video just write them below in
the comments what's going to happen is
there'll be some new DC coming later
today but if there any other Marvel
videos that you guys want me to do
before Comic Con just let me know in the
comments there's going to be a two-hour
Marvel panel so there's going to be a
whole bunch of special Marvel stuff at
Comic Con congratulations to the latest
giveaway winner Erik Perez please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details while you wait for everything
you can click here for my post credits
video and you can click here for my
breakdown of the timeline air that eight
years later at the beginning of the
movie thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight